passer au débat sur le loup justement on
va parler de cette problématique
longuement pendant ce club d'abord pour
commencer le débat avec voudrais on va
voir les chiffres est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de loups en France alors Oriane
difficile d'avoir un comptage
extrêmement précis mais d'après l'Office
national de la biodiversité chargée du
suivi et du recensement Lupin il y
aurait
921 loups ce sont des loups-gris en
France et 128 meutes des loups répartis
dans les principaux massifs montagneux
et essentiellement dans le sud et l'est
de la France dans les Alpes notamment on
le voit ici sur cette carte du réseau
louny lynx qu'on va vous montrer mais il
peut y avoir des individus ou des meutes
de façon plus sporadique on en a même
aperçu près des grandes villes Marseille
notamment et le loup c'est une espèce
extrêmement protégée alors avant toute
chose il faut savoir qu'en France au 18e
siècle il y avait entre 15000 et 20000
lourds est parti sur tout le territoire
il y a eu ensuite une grande campagne
d'éradication à la fin des années 30 on
considère que l'espèce a totalement
disparu de notre pays mais le peut faire
jusqu'à 100 km par jour et les
frontières ne l'arrêtent pas donc on
imagine que ce sont des loups venus
d'Italie qui sont en France aujourd'hui
on fait maintenant un saut dans le temps
dans les années 90 la France ratifie la
Convention de Berne qui protège la vie
sauvage en milieu naturel le loup est
une espèce strictement protégée depuis
cette date interdiction de le tuer sauf
dérogation préfectorale dans certains
cas précis prévention des dommages aux
cultures aux bétail ou intérêts de santé
publique une personne qui tue un loup en
dehors de ces dérogations en cours deux
ans de prison et 150000 euros d'amende
voilà pour les chiffres merci beaucoup
Audrey est-ce que Cédric Vial
aujourd'hui le loup est un problème en
France ah oui il est il est devenu il
est devenu un problème
pour toute une activité économique et
agricole de notre pays
vous l'avez dit il a été réintroduit
c'est pas naturel il a été réintroduit
et en trentaine d'années on se
retrouvait dans une situation où on
avait plus de loup en France à une ou le
loup prolifère et où si on continue
comme ça on laisse faire comme ça c'est
plus le loup qui va falloir protéger
mais c'est nos éleveurs et c'est les
alpagistes qui deviennent une espèce à
protéger donc il y a un vrai problème on
est en train de perdre le contrôle de la
population lipine et on a dépassé
j'allais dire exploser le terme est un
peu fort mais il correspond à ce qu'on
ressent sur le territoire c'est cette
population lupine on n'est plus dans la
préservation de l'espèce aujourd'hui
elle est dans des dans des quantités qui
sont
qui qui garantissent sa survie
maintenant il faut prendre des mesures
si on veut garder une activité alpestre
Jean-Michel Bertrand la réponse
j'imagine que vous n'avez pas la même
réponse à cette question est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui le lot est un problème
est-ce qu'on peut parler de
prolifération
écoutez j'ai failli m'étrangler les gens
bonjour monsieur le sénateur avec tout
mon respect
jusqu'à preuve du contraire mais nous
non absolument pas été réintroduit c'est
un enfant je trouve bêtement et on peut
prouver évidemment c'est ce retour
naturel depuis les japonais depuis le
massif et des acné en Italie ou le loup
a été protégé dans des années 70 et avec
le système de la déesse on peut voir
d'où proviennent chez nous et comment
s'est passé cette forme de
recolonisation donc déjà le loup n'a pas
été introduit par des méchants écolo
bobos il est revenu naturellement parce
que tous les parfaits tous les feux sont
tous les signaux sont ouverts pour lui
il y a eu un vrai abandon évidemment
connaît moi qui vit dans le champion
dans les Hautes-Alpes un exode rural
massif au cours du 20e siècle il y a eu
ces vastes plans de reforestin de
représentation d'arbres de la part de
l'Office des forêts à la fin du 19e
début du 20e
le retour des ongles est sauvages bref
tout était
tout était fait pour que les loups
reviennent naturellement à partir du
moment où ils étaient protégés en Italie
alors est-ce que le loup est un problème
où évidemment le loup a posé des
problèmes avec son retour au monde de
l'élevage et du passe-temporainisme
c'est une évidence un grand prédateur
opportuniste n'arrive pas comme ça dans
la douceur c'est un animal qui peut
faire des dégâts sur des sur les
troupeaux évidemment et c'est là et
c'est à cela qu'il faut essayer de
s'atteler c'est-à-dire essayer de pas
d'ailleurs même s'il y a un déni parce
que ça fait maintenant 30 ans que le
loup a commencé à harmonir par le
Mercantour même s'il y a un déni on voit
bien que que les choses ont beaucoup
changé c'est-à-dire qu'on a des
troupeaux plus petits on a le métier de
berger qui a à nouveau explosé c'est à
dire que moi dans les intentions et
quand j'étais gamin il y avait quasiment
plus le berger il y avait deux trois
vieux bergers
dans des conditions terribles pour
garder quelques troupeaux aujourd'hui
vous avez des dizaines j'étais bien des
dizaines de bergers rien de chez nous
dans notre valet qui sont logés de façon
beaucoup plus convenable avec des
cabanes rénovées etc donc c'est tout un
système qui remet en place si ça ne
protection avec des chiens etc même si
il y a encore un énorme travail à faire
bref je crois que plutôt que d'aller
vers des mensonges ou des friction
inutile de vouloir rendre des coudre le
problème c'est vraiment cette fameuse
foi existence laquelle nous ne pourrons
échapper et essayer d'aller dans ce
sens-là mais deux grâces ne répétez pas
s'il vous plaît que le loup a été
réintroduit parce que c'est quelque
chose de totalement faux je vais laisser
je vais laisser Cédric
parce que c'est pas le jeu mais à partir
du moment alors bien sûr on n'est pas
allé le chercheur en voiture pour le
ramener il est venu tout seul mais à
partir du moment où on met en place une
organisation de l'État autour du loup et
des pour permettre leur développement
jusqu'à un certain niveau et jusqu'à je
pense aujourd'hui un niveau qui nous
dépasse on a appris des mesures qui s'il
y avait une volonté de réintroduction du
loup même si encore une fois même si
enfin c'est quand même l'État qui a
organisé et les pouvoirs publics qui ont
organisé le développement de la
population il y avait une donc une vraie
volonté de faire ça c'est ce que ce que
je voulais dire
parce qu'on va après on va aller en
Lozère on y va maintenant parce que le
problème on aura le temps d'en parler
c'est le problème c'est évidemment la
cohabitation du loup avec les éleveurs
et les loups qui attaquent les bêtes
Audrey vous allez nous emmener en Lozère
vous y êtes allés ou le préfet vient
d'autoriser des tirs de prélèvement du
loup c'est une première pour cette
espèce protégée oui et ce que j'ai pu
voir en fait c'est que la cohabitation
entre les éleveurs et le loup est devenu
vraiment indispensable insupportable
pardon et ça crée des témoignages
extrêmement bouleversants regardez
je vais venir depuis plus de deux mois
Perrine runal Galzin fait tout ce
qu'elle peut pour sauver sa brebis
chaque jour elle répète les mêmes gestes
on fait des plâtres pour accélérer la
cicatrisation et
éviter tout infection celle-ci donc a
été retrouvée contre la bergerie apeuré
avec une éventration abdominale en
ouverture là mais aucun organe vitaux de
toucher cet été le cheptel de Perrine a
été attaqué trois fois en trois mois
voilà c'est les perforations donc que
font donc la signature du Louvre parfois
à quelques mètres seulement des
habitations et c'est tellement adapté et
acclimatée à notre à nos terrains que
l'eau de rubaine ou l'activité humaine
ne le dérange plus elle avait 110 bêtes
elle n'en a plus que 75 et les
survivante effrayés ne mettent plus bas
une situation difficile à vivre pour
Perrine
moi j'ai repris le cheptel familial
depuis le 1er janvier 2022 mais je me
doutais pas que j'allais vivre
une année 2022 aussi meurtrière et aussi
des Hollande quoi c'est
en Lozère 180 mètres d'élevage aurait
été tués par les loups depuis le début
de l'année contre 70 en 2019 face à
cette situation exceptionnelle le préfet
vient d'autoriser des chasseurs à
sermenter à abattre des loups dans la
région de la Margeride une première en
Lozère car l'espèce est strictement
protégée mais Perrine n'est pas
concernée son exploitation se situe dans
le parc national des Cévennes c'est
aussi le cas de Martine Chaptal elle a
perdu 12 bêtes cet été je m'y attendais
je savais qu'un jour ça arriverait dans
le parc elle n'a le droit de tirer sur
le loup que s'il l'attaque je n'ai
jamais utilisé un arbre avec moi le loup
il risque rien pas de danger pour le
loup avec moi entrée d'humour qui masque
difficilement son angoisse pour l'avenir
de la profession j'ai un jeune qui est
au village qui veut s'installer et on
est ravis que ce jeune soit intéressé il
est natif du village et qu'est-ce qu'on
lui dit pour l'installer en brebis s'il
y a des loups en Lozère terre agricoles
et pastorale rares sont ceux qui
défendent le loup les politiques ont
choisi le camp de leurs éleveurs
Guylaine panel sénatrice du département
veut remettre une proposition de loi au
goût du jour il faut la Lozère soit une
terre d'exclusion du loup quoi tout
simplement c'est aussi simple que ça et
puis c'est interdit de vache donc à
partir de là on peut pas concilier les
deux créer des zones d'exclusion ça veut
dire que l'abattage de l'eau est
autorisée dans les zones d'exclusion
indépendamment du prélèvement
du niveau national quoi donner au niveau
national et puis les zones d'exclusion
pas en péril évidemment le loup en
France quoi ça c'est ça n'a rien à voir
c'est simplement une protection sur les
zones d'élevage j'aimerais je souhaite
qu'elle passe pour pour apaiser le
chemin s'annonce compliqué cette idée a
déjà été rejetée par l'Assemblée
nationale il y a 10 ans
et on le voit Cédric Jean que la
bataille du loup par des chasseurs c'est
une bonne méthode
c'est la seule méthode aujourd'hui enfin
il y a deux solutions soit on est pour
l'éradication du loup c'est la position
qui avait pris la France dans les au
début du 20e siècle on l'avait dit on
l'a éradiqué en 1930 parce qu'on
considérait que sa présence était
incompatible avec avec l'activité
agricole aujourd'hui on est plus dans
cette logique là et je défends pas cette
position on est dans une logique de
cohabitation qui doit permettre à la
fois à l'espèce de de survivre et et là
on a il va falloir estimer quelle est la
population qui est nécessaire à l'espèce
avait été estimé à 500 individus
et pour permettre d'avoir un certain
nombre de nuisances mais une
cohabitation qui reste possible avec les
activités humaines aujourd'hui vous
l'avez dit l'ofb estiman à 980
qui qui est le nombre minimum l'année
dernière ils avaient estimé à la même
période à 600 à 600 loups ils ont
réévalué à 800 900 ils vont probablement
réévaluer à 1200
des éleveurs eux estiment plutôt à 3000
la population pourquoi parce que eux ils
sont sur des bases scientifiques c'est
les loups dont ils ont la certitude des
preuves scientifiques de la présence ça
veut pas dire qu'ils ont tous identifié
on est probablement plus près des deux
ou trois mille espèces de la même façon
qu'ils étudient le loup scientifiquement
on a des loups des qu'on appelle des
hybrides qui sont de race qui sont moins
purs
la question pour l'éleveur que ce soit
un hybride à 95% ou un loup à 100%, elle
est la même donc on a une prolifération
de l'espèce et donc une augmentation des
des attaques qui n'est plus compatible
si on continue comme ça dans deux ans je
vous dis c'est les éleveurs qu'il faudra
protéger pour compléter il y a quelque
chose qui m'a vraiment surpris en Lozère
c'est que ça a été extrêmement difficile
de trouver des gens qui étaient pour le
loup il y a vraiment un ras-le-bol du
côté des éleveurs parce que c'est une
terre qui est vraiment très pastorale et
ils sont trop massisés je dirais
notamment l'éleveuse Perrine que vous
voyez au début du reportage parce qu'en
fait elle a elle a trouvé ses bêtes
agonisantes et le temps que les
constatations en fait pour après les
indemnisations elle n'avait pas le droit
de les abattre donc c'est vrai que ça a
été assez difficile pour elle sur ce
plan là et on sent qu'ils ont été assez
fortement touchés du côté des bergers ça
impacte aussi leur vie de famille parce
que cet été du coup ils ont dormi avec
leurs troupeau quelque chose qui faisait
pas forcément les années auparavant
ouais Jean-Michel Bertrand vous
l'entendez la détresse de ses éleveurs
qui voient leur bête attaqué par des
loups qui les retrouvent agonisantes
quand j'étais gamin
il y avait pas de loup il y avait chez
ma Meuse attaques de gérant vous savez
avec ce qu'on appelle le surplus feeling
que pratique les lots ou des chiens ou
tous les prédateurs quand il y a panique
dans un propos et c'est jamais joli joli
d'avoir sauf que quand il s'agit de
chien qui attaquent quand il s'agit de
dérangements dual orage on a eu à louer
s'il y a quelques années 200 brebis qui
ont sauté à cause de l'orage et pas à
cause des loups pour le coup on en a
jamais entendu parler et lorsqu'on a des
attaques de loup c'est tout de suite une
victimisation outrance alors tout ça
n'est pas pour dénigrer évidemment les
problèmes et la souffrance d'un berger
ou d'un éleveur qui se retrouve
confronté à la prédation mais on est
clairement dans une instrumentalisation
de l'animal et quand vous parlez de la
Lozère ou les gens n'en peuvent plus il
y a quasiment pas de l'eau en Lozère
dans les Alpes il y en a quand même
beaucoup c'est là qui est le berceau de
l'espèce et
venant de la Fédération ovine vous
pouvez vérifier ces chiffres le seul
endroit en France où le l'élevage ovince
pour tuto moins mal qu'ailleurs et où
sur la carte c'est en vert et bien c'est
la région PACA c'est la région dans
laquelle il y a le plus de loups alors
vous voyez il y a quand même des choses
un peu étonnantes alors je dis pas que
c'est le tout évidemment ça qui fait que
il y a plus de d'élevage qui se porte
mieux dans ces endroits là mais
simplement
ces éleveurs faut les soutenir je pense
que l'État se charge de les soutenir et
il y a des tas de de aujourd'hui de de
d'initiatives de bénévoles de gens qui
viennent aider les bergers les éleveurs
sur le terrain quand ils ont des
problèmes donc je crois qu'il faut
surtout pas aller dans cette
instrumentalisation cette victimisation
parce que c'est trop facile je veux dire
de filmer des gens en pleurs on peut en
filmer tout le temps et partout et avec
le loup c'est systématique je vous dis
les les les causes de décès vous parlez
de 180 mètres que tu es en Lozère je
suis désolé c'est beaucoup trop toujours
comme on dit UNE de trop c'est toujours
trop une de plus c'est toujours trop
mais 180 c'est juste dérisoire par
rapport à une mortalité à la mortalité
des bêtes en Lozère cet été donc voyez
il faut relativiser tout ça prend un
petit peu de recul et à ce moment-là
avancer vous savez il y a une il y a une
maxime qui n'est pas la mienne mais
j'adore et quand on m'a on me l'a dit
qu'il y a quelques jours mais j'adore
quand on veut quelque chose quand on
veut quelque chose on s'en donne les
moyens quand on en veut pas on se
cherche des excuses et avec les loups on
est complètement là dedans c'est à dire
tous les prétextes sont bons pour viver
victimiser tendre créer des tensions
alors qu'on doit aller vers une
ouverture et je pense clairement
aujourd'hui que la société civile l'État
qui a d'ailleurs déjà beaucoup beaucoup
les éleveurs et l'émerger et bien c'est
la solidarité nationale doit aussi être
relayée par des citoyens qui vont le
terrain et des émerger ses éleveurs et
j'en parle dans mon prochain film que je
suis en train de tourner et je pense
qu'il faut plus aller vers la
bienveillance vers l'empathie vers
l'écoute en constatant les problèmes
effectivement réels que peuvent
provoquer ces animaux plutôt que d'aller
dans le clivage et dans le mensonge
parce que il y a des choses qu'il faut
pas dire et on va aller Cédric Vial sur
ce que vous disiez sur l'élevage les
trois départements les plus touchés par
les prédations de loot c'est les Alpes
de Haute-Provence les Alpes-Maritimes en
région PACA et votre département de la
Savoie en région Verdun je crois qu'on
vient de toucher du doigt le cœur du
problème vous avez raison sur un point
monsieur il y a des choses qu'il faut
pas dire vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
je vous le dis à votre tour entendre
parler d'outrans de victimisation
excessive ou d'instrumentalisation je
trouve ça choquant monsieur je vous le
dis à mon tour je pense qu'il faut bien
comprendre une chose que les gens qui
nous écoutent comprennent bien une chose
quand il y a une attaque de loup c'est
pas un prélèvement le loup vient pas
prélever une bête et repartir avec et
tout se passe bien
[Musique]
au lendemain il ils ont des situations
qui qui ressemblent à des carnages on
peut pas parler d'instrumentalisation de
victimisation c'est c'est insupportable
d'entendre ça il faut se mettre à côté
de ces situations et on voit le loup des
centres de plus moi j'habite en
Chartreuse c'est un un massif de moyenne
montagne ou il y a trois quatre ans en
arrière on entendait pas parler du loup
aujourd'hui on le voit dans le village
la nuit on a des images dans le dans les
villages on a des attaques dit depuis un
mois et demi j'ai fait le point avec un
collègue il y a quelques jours on a eu
plus de 25 attaques en un mois en un
mois et demi sur des territoires de
moyenne montagne c'est plus de 500
attaques recensés cette saison en Savoie
ça devient insupportable le phénomène
nous dépasse et pour terminer on va
aller voir puisque Audrey vous l'avez
dit le lot il arrive le loup il arrive
aussi dans les zones urbaines et
notamment du côté de Marseille et on y
va on trouve Guilhem ricavier bonjour
Guilhem merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeur des rédactions du groupe La
Provence le loup vous en avez beaucoup
parlé dans vos éditions de La Provence
il y a quelques jours car une de l'eau
est aperçu aux portes de Marseille
oui a été aperçu aux portes de Marseille
à La Penne-sur-Huveaune plus exactement
c'est à l'est de la ville entre
Marseille et Aubagne et c'est là que
Sylvie est bien élevé 24 brebis 24
chèvres et donc et bien dans la nuit du
24 au 25 septembre dernier elles ont été
attaquées 12 ont été tués et dépecer
leur de cette attaque alors bien
évidemment les agents de l'Office
français de la biodiversité sont venus
mener en quête et ils ont bien attesté
d'une attaque de loupe ce qui a confirmé
également et bien des images de vidéos
surveillance d'une caméra thermique
installée qui a montré la présence de
deux loups sur les lieux de la taxe
n'est pas vraiment une nouveauté puisque
des loups cela fait maintenant deux ans
que l'on en aperçoit dans le Parc
national des Calanques qui est tout
proche ce qui est nouveau et c'est pour
ça que cette attaque a fait beaucoup
parler c'est que le loup n'avait jamais
tué aussi bas on est habitué ici à la
Provence aux attaques de loups dans les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence et les
Hautes-Alpes dans quasi quotidienne
hebdomadaire mais en tout cas jamais le
loup aux portes de Marseille n'avait ne
s'en était pris pardon à un troupeau et
c'est pour ça que cette attaque a fait
beaucoup parler Oriane
oui très clairement depuis le retour du
loup en 1992 il est arrivé par les Alpes
le loup et maintenant présent quand on
regarde les témoignages et les
déclarations faites à l'Office français
de la biodiversité le loup est présent
dans les départements alpins dans le Var
également désormais dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône et le Vaucluse et les
attaques là aussi se multiplient
hebdomadaires les témoignages de berger
d'éleveurs dans le 04 raconte tous la
même chose ils sont donc très nombreux
au niveau national on estime qu'il y a à
peu près 3700 attaques de loups par an
ça ce sont les attaques qui sont
réellement déclarés parce que certains
éleveurs ovins notamment dans les Alpes
reconnaissent parfois ne même plus
parfois déclarer les attaques tellement
elles sont devenues fréquentes merci
merci beaucoup Guilhem merci d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous parler de ça et Marc
créneau qui était en déplacement dans la
région Guilhem il était dans les
alpes-de-provence à Digne-les-Bains et
il a évoqué la possibilité d'assouplir
la directive européenne habitat de 92
qui protège les Louis folas soupir pour
vous c'est une bonne idée oui je pense
que c'est la meilleure solution à moyen
ou long terme parce que on sait que ça
prend du temps c'est négociations qui
étaient européenne aujourd'hui
on appelle ça l'annexe 2 de la
Convention de Berne c'est à dire que
loup est une espèce dite strictement
protégée l'objectif c'est de la changer
dans cette annexe et de la passer en
espèces protégée qui permettra de
faciliter les prélèvements de maintenir
une population de loups mais sans sans
se laisser déborder par la prolifération
ouais Jean-Michel Bernard il nous reste
30 secondes Marc créneau qui a également
dit je le cite la population de loups
est plutôt dynamique c'est un point
positif pour la biodiversité mais on a
atteint une limite de notre capacité à
maintenir un système pastoral
aujourd'hui c'est la fin de la
cohabitation entre le loup et les
éleveurs
non non c'est vraiment le début de la
coexistence et la cohabitation moi je me
dis je rencontre l'état d'éleveur et
vous le verrez dans mon prochain film
qui qui sont des gens qui prennent la
chose avec philosophie on va dire qu'ils
se disent on fait avec ou on fait pas
avec toutes les techniques de protection
basique qui sont pratiqués depuis la
nuit des temps et qui sont toujours
pratiqués dans des pays où les loups
n'ont pas disparu que sont les bergers
les chiens les clôtures de nuit et je
vous dis aujourd'hui on est dans une
espèce d'instrumentalisation je le redis
ce qui ne l'enlève en rien les problèmes
que peut causer nous et les ennuis qui
peuvent aborder ces memeurs ou les
bergers avec au travers des attaques
surtout pas je respecte complètement ces
gens là je le dis et je me redis car je
parle d'instrumentalisation et de
victimisation je parle d'un côté
politique le loup est un animal
politique vous le savez bien et si vous
voulez comme vous le dites et c'est très
bien monsieur sénateur qu'il continue à
y avoir des loups et ben il continuera y
avoir des problèmes parce que on traite
souvent les écolos d'être hors-sol de
rêver mais quand il me dites que vous
voulez des loups mais à la et pas là et
pas ailleurs mais c'est impossible c'est
l'animal de Playmobil Jean-Michel
Bernard
merci juste très rapidement Cédric je
dis pas qu'il en faut là ou là je dis
cette situation elle me fait penser à
celle de l'hôpital il y a une situation
qui est préoccupante très préoccupante
et la table d'après c'est trop tard là
aujourd'hui on est dans la situation
très préoccupante si on prend pas des
mesures rapidement de maïs sera trop
tard on pourra plus compter sur les
alpagistes pour nous aider quand ils
seront plus là
[Musique]